[Musique]
même si les grands rassemblements sont
interdits la pandémie ne gâchera pas la
fête
fred pellerin est ce qui reste du monde
de bottes au québec à soir paul piché
bien sûr et la rue
enfin mon corps car des pirates
[Musique]
plus d'une quarantaine d'artistes
prendront part aux célébrations animé
par terre lapointe et ariane moffatt
un rendez vous que les artistes ne
voulait pas manquer je suis sûr que tout
le monde est très très ému très excitée
d'être tous présents au moins pour dire
bonjour au monde pour faire pour qu'on
fait ensemble
on les verra pas c'est sûr on est
habitué à voir ben déjà des milliers de
personnes mais là on va c'est imaginer
les milieux personnes chacun chez eux
sous le thème tout le québec à l'unisson
le concert sera retransmis sur les cinq
grands réseaux de télévision
c'est ainsi c'est le tape plus que
jamais de faire une fête qui vaut
vraiment être rassembleuse où on va
inviter tous les québécois et
québécoises tout le monde avec qui on
partage nos territoires à fêter avec
nous le spectacle sera tourné à
l'amphithéâtre de trois rivières dans
des conditions sanitaires strictes mais
pour les organisateurs il était
impensable de ne pas souligner
l'événement cette facture unique et très
spécial on voit se rappeler c'est
l'heure parce que on se sera pas comme
d'habitude des festivités qui se
dérouleront sous le signe de la
résilience en cette année qui a éprouvé
plusieurs de nos concitoyens et sinaly
alexandre charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]